the Atomium in Brussels represents an
elementary iron crystal enlarged 165
billion times this unusual structure has
been the Belgian capitals most
distinctive landmark for close to 60
years built as a symbol for the peaceful
use of nuclear power the Atomium
continues to attract visitors in droves
[Music]
Alexandre Laurent has been taking
pictures of this imposing structure for
over a decade from the ground and from
the air
his passion for the Atomium knows no
bounds the money more keifa's he offered
a hockey it's a monument that's
especially fascinating in photographs
it's like a mirror which reflects the
sky and the ground colours change
according to the season one time it's
red blue and the next time Green Hill
the clouds also play a role visitors
take away a different impression of this
structure every time but what it Sulekha
more surety inside they can travel
through 23 meter long tubes from one
sphere to the next rising ever higher
here people get to see another side of
the Atomium
the next day of the victim Odile from
the outside it looks very modern shiny
and lovely took the moon musket on the
inside it's quite rough the spheres and
tubes are crude and give the Atomium an
industrial feel boo HT with this
building Belgium wanted to show what it
could do at the time these pictures show
the Atomium under construction in the
late 1950s built for the 1958 Brussels
World's Fair it was to be a futuristic
prestige project 102 metres tall the
structure featured nine aluminum clad
spheres the Atomium was supposed to be
torn down after Expo 58 ended but it
proved such a hit that it was left
standing and even had the outer shell
redone in stainless steel almost six
decades later the building has become a
national symbol an exhibition recalls
the early days what it meant to the
people it was like coming here and
having the WoW feeling this is what
Belgium can show this is what we want to
show to the world what what the small
Belgian country can do it was the first
Exposition also after World World War
two so it was really the whole world
coming here and all the countries
showing off what they could their
technology their knowledge
to this day the famous landmark has lost
none of its fascination 600,000 people
flocked to the Atomium each year making
it one of Belgium's biggest tourist
attractions and most take a picture as a
reminder of their visit euro max asked
our viewers around the world to send in
their best shots from their trip to
Brussels with the Atomium the size of
everything the tubes and everything it's
really pretty nice to see SATA kcal/kg
Ania it's quite old so it's great that
it's still profits from tourism today
there's a booth of Silla I'm glad to
have seen it the two E's will decide
lesson I like the architecture best from
inside and out the 45th tm4c building it
was certainly a big achievement and it
offers a great view of Brussels Beth get
spoiled a day that's at the top it's a
even for Alexander Lauren a visit to the
Atomium wouldn't be complete without a
look out over the city the ride on the
elevator is a highlight in itself the
world's fastest at the time it was built
the elevator whisks visitors to 102
metres above ground in 23 seconds at the
top is what many consider the nicest
panoramic view of the city almost an old
war machine for me it's a magical place
and a view of a brothels of the
surrounding area is fantastic you can
discover interesting details about the
city it'd be some happy little is like
looking out the window of an airplane
you're a connoisseur la belgique I
always like to come back up here Vox at
Lu kitchen be a faculty the Atomium the
Belgian Capitals most famous landmark is
an impressive sight no matter how you
look at it
[Music]